well the president tweeted out about the
FBI scandal controversy over a quote if
the person placed very early into my
campaign wasn't a spy put there by
previous administration for political
purposes how comes such a seemingly
massive amount of money was paid for
services rendered many times higher than
normal
follow the money the spy was there early
in the campaign yet never reported
collusion with Russia because there was
no collusion he was only there to spy
for political reasons and help crooked
Hillary win just like they did to poor
Bernie Sanders who got duped that's so
true joining us with reaction Republican
Congressman Jim Jordan Mac cake no one
ever talks Bernie Sanders the whole
thing was raked but Jim Jordan let me
start with you there's a lot happening
tonight number one your letter there and
there are a hundred congressmen that
want you to be speaker and frankly I
would like to see you be the next
speaker when there's a race Shawn I plan
to be I plan on being part of that
discussion there's not one now what we
got to focus on is doing what the
American people sent us here to do over
the next few months so that we can stay
in the majority and help Donald Trump
accomplish the things that the American
people elected us to do and that's what
I'm focused on doing yeah all right
let's talk about where we are today
congressman gates I have zero faith in
rod Rosen Stein and the DOJ to actually
hand over the documents because we know
specific documents will be absolutely
damning if they come out against these
very people why would they do that to
themselves well on Shawn that's one of
the reasons why I don't believe at the
upcoming meeting the chairman Nunez is
having with members of the intelligence
community that there will be any
production of documents and that's
deeply concerning to me if you have to
look at the scoreboard right now the
deep state is winning the battle because
they are in full control of their own
destiny that's why congressman Lee
Zeldin and Jim Jordan and I joined with
more than two dozen of our colleagues to
call for a second special counsels
that's a process Julie she would think
it is the best what the Inspector
General's ridiculous because these days
new ones into the Clinton email
investigation we don't have that kind of
time well in Shawn this will be a reason
for them to delay the Inspector General
report because now we're back in
Inspector General land and so now we
won't get the answers on Hillary
well as separate and apart and that has
already been handed over as I understand
it Jim Jordan here's the problem we have
though we have FISA abuse we know no out
right judges were lied to it in
literally the single biggest intrusion
into a person's constitutional rights
yeah a FISA warrant four times they lied
the bulk of information that phony
dossier they never told the judge who
paid for it right so judges the
Department of Justice says don't worry
we can investigate ourselves even though
as you say they took a dossier to a
secret court to get a secret warrant
didn't tell the court who paid for it
namely the Clinton campaign didn't tell
the court that the author of the
document Christopher Steele had been
fired by the FBI they say don't worry we
can investigate ourselves even though it
now appears there were paid informants
who were hanging around the periphery of
the Trump campaign they expect us to
investigate but this is what you think
of what you're saying spies in the
campaign yes
lying to judges to get Biser warrants to
spy on an opposition party candidate
with propaganda from Russia put together
by a foreign national that was full of
lies and literally they don't tell the
judges in any I cannot believe I
wouldn't write this in a spy novel
because I wouldn't think anybody would
believe it Jeff Sessions says only under
extraordinary circumstances do you name
a special count now how about the fact
that top five people the FBI have been
fired or demoted those same people who
ran the Clinton investigation who
launched the Russian investigation who
used the opposition research document at
the FISA Court and now look like they
paid informants to be a part of the
Trump campaign how about that for a fact
pattern that's extraordinary if that's
not extraordinary hey that's why Jim
George should be Speaker of the House
then we'd have some real oversight
checkmate I'm not gonna argue all right
by the way for the record I'm supporting
Jim Jordan I just endorsed them that
might be the case add a quorum thank you
both all right